हेलो गैस वेलकम तू अवर युटुब चैनल
डेफ्रॉनिक्स अकादमी मेरा नाम है आयुष पाठक
और आज नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी के लेक्चर फाइव
में आप सबका स्वागत है तो सबसे पहले तो आप
सबके लिए बहुत साड़ी बधाइयां और आप सबको
बहुत सर थैंक यू क्योंकि आपने हमारे थ्री
के सब्सक्राइबर्स जो है कंप्लीट कर दिए
हैं देख सकते हैं आप इस तरीके से आप लोग
अगर सपोर्ट करते रहेंगे तो हमारे चैनल भी
काफी दूर हो जाएगा और हम भी आपके लिए काफी
सारे कंटेंट जो है ला पाएंगे ठीक है तो कर
स्ट्रक्चर जो हमने कर लिए थे ऑलरेडी
नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी के पहले ही उम्मीद
करता हूं की कर लेक्चर आपने देख लिए होंगे
आपको बढ़िया लगा होगा क्योंकि फिर विधायक
को तो टेलीग्राम दुनिया कीजिए वो कमेंट कर
दिया कीजिए और कोई डाउट हो तो वो भी आप
लोग पूछ सकते हैं टेलीग्राम पे ठीक है तो
अगर 4 लेक्चर आपने कर लिया अच्छे से आपको
सब कुछ समझ में ए चुका है तो आज हम लोग
करने वाले हैं यहां पर पांच वाले अक्षर और
अर्जुन को पहले मैं ट्रैक नहीं ओपन कर लेट
हूं यहां पर अगर मैं ए जाता हूं
यहां मॉडल्स में चले जाते हैं
और यहां पर हम लोग नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी के
मॉडल को स्टार्ट करने वाले हैं ठीक है
बेसिक कंप्लीट
लाइव में शादी करूंगा यह भी
तो सबसे पहले बात कर लेते हैं तो पहले मैं
आपको एक यहां पर इमेज दिखता हूं
क्या यहां पर स्टेप वन
गेनिंग एक्सेस पर मेंटेंनिंग एक्सरसाइज
आपका क्लीयरिंग ड्राइव ठीक है ये आप का
सकते हैं की एक तरीके से एथिकल एक्टिंग के
जनरल स्टेप्स हैं मतलब हम लोग किस तरीके
से कम करते हैं सबसे पहले हम त्रिकोण करते
हैं रेकों को इनफॉरमेशन कहा जा सकता है
खाने का मतलब ये की अपनी टारगेट को जानना
है उसके स्कोप को जानना है ठीक है और ये
सब चीज आईडेंटिफाई करना ये रिकॉर्ड में
आता है इसके बाद स्कैनिंग कर सकते हैं
यहां पे एनीमेशन का सकते हैं इसमें आप इस
टारगेट को और इधर ए न्यू क्रिएट कर रहे
होते हैं उसमें घुस रहा है घुसेंगे आप और
उसमें और चीजों को समझेंगे उसके बड़े में
थर्ड स्टेप में एक एक्स को जेन करते हैं
मतलब आप एक्सपेक्टेशन कम करते हैं असली
में ठीक है यहां पर आपको एक इनिशियल
फुटबॉल चाहिए होता है मतलब एक आपका कम ए
जाए सिस्टम पे उतना कम वो करना होता है
फोर्थ में करता है मेंटेंनिंग एक्सरसाइज
यहां पर आपका वो सर कम है आपका मतलब की
असिस्टेंट वाला है ये सब कम वो आपको करना
होता है और फिर आपको अपने जो है तो ये
एथिकल हैकिंग का एक जनरल वो है ठीक है ऐसा
नहीं है इस तरीके से कम कर रही है थोड़ा
ये साइकिल टाइप का प्रोसेस है मतलब की ये
कौन है स्प्लिटीशन से चला राहत है ठीक है
लेकिन खाने मतलब यह की जनरल
करेंगे इसके साथ-साथ जहां जहां जरूर पड़ती
रहेगी ना अपनी तरफ से एक्स्ट्रा चीजों को
एड करता रहूंगा ठीक है ना तो ये नहीं
समझिएगा की ये लिप करने की फायदा नहीं है
मतलब वीडियो देखने का है सिर्फ वही तो बता
रहे हैं जो यहां लिखा हुआ है उससे
एक्स्ट्रा चीज आपको मिलेगी सही तरीके से
मिलेंगे डिटेल में समझाऊंगा और आपको जो है
क्लियर होगी और जिसके पास पेड़ अकाउंट
नहीं है अगर यहां पर जो भी विप का जरूर
होंगे करियर स्टार्टिंग तीन फ्री है इसके
बाद जो ये आई है वो भी आप देख सकते हैं
यहां से ये सारे बेनिफिट आपको मिलने वाले
हैं तो ओपन कर लेट हूं पहले मैं इसको
चलिए तो यहां पर वही चीज दी हुई है पहले
ये दिया हुआ है हम लोग करने वाले हैं इस
पूरे बॉडी ड्यूल में तो आज फिलहाल मैं
पहले रूम कर रहे हैं और जितना हो पाएगा
उत्स देखा जाएगा फिर आगे किया जाएगा ठीक
है तो सबसे पहले कॉन्फ्रेंस में मैं आपको
एक चीज और बता डन की कौन सी दो टाइप का
होता है ठीक है एक होता है आपका एक्टिव
कौन से और एक होता है आपका पैसिव रिकने से
होते हैं इसके बड़े में भी हमें आगे
देखेंगे अभी पहले ये देख सकते हैं
[संगीत]
आपका की नेटवर्क फंडामेंटल जो हमने कर
लिया है पूरा कंप्लीट ठीक है ये आपका होना
चाहिए
आपका होना चाहिए तो ये हमने नहीं किया है
लेकिन सर मैंने आपको कर दिया है तो वो
आपने देखा होगा ठीक है कोई दिक्कत नहीं
होगी इसको पहले ये कंप्लीट कर दीजिए यहां
पे क्या लिखा हुआ है यहां पे लिखा है आपको
अटैक बॉक्स में चालू कर देना या तो अपने
डीएम में कनेक्ट कर लीजिए चालू कर
सकते हैं
क्या होता है अगर आपको नहीं बताया तो यह
आपको एक लिंक सिस्टम देता है जो इनके
नेटवर्क में कनेक्ट है तो मतलब इनकी कोई
भी मशीन को आप डायरेक्टली अटैक बॉक्स से
एक्सेस कर सकते हैं अटैक कर सकते हैं ठीक
है अगर आपका प्रीमियम अकाउंट है तो आपको
ज्यादा एक्सेस मिलता है वरना आपको मैं कल
से एक या दो घंटे का ये मिलता है फिलहाल
मैं ओपन कर रहा हूं यहां पर यह कुछ टाइम
हो गया चालू होने में तब तक हम लोग आगे
देखते रहते हैं और चीजों के बड़े में इसको
यहां पर कंप्लीटेड सिलेक्ट कर दीजिए हो
जाएगा कंप्लीट
इंटरेक्शन था और कुछ आसानी से इसमें टास्क
2 पे आते हैं यहां पर पैसे एक्टिवेट हो जो
मैंने आपको बताया की रिकंसीज दो टाइप का
होता है एक्टिवेट पैसे टाइप का ठीक है देख
लेते हैं वो क्या होता है
[संगीत]
एक यूनिफाइड किचन के बड़े में बताना
चाहूंगा आपको मैं इससे आपको अच्छे से समझ
में आएगा पहले देख लेते हैं यहां पर ओपन
करता हूं
ठीक है ये तीन स्टेप मैं आपको दिखे रहा है
पहले स्टेप है गेटिंग इन ठीक है सेकंड
स्टेप आपका क्या है यहां पर हैकिंग थ्रू
और सेकंड स्टेप को क्या है टेकन आईटी आउट
देखिए इसका मतलब क्या होता है पहले आपको
अंदर जाना है सिस्टम के देखो किस तरीके से
सबसे पहले आपको रेकों करना है ठीक है मतलब
इनफॉरमेशन के अधिनिया को ये सब चीज सिर्फ
आपको रिसोर्सेस डेवलपमेंट करना है ठीक है
डिलीवरी करना है मतलब अपने त्रिकोण किया
आपको जो भी समझ में आया की ये रिक्वेस्ट
हो शक्ति है उसके हिसाब से अपनी चीज तैयार
की और फिर इंजीनियरिंग की थ्रू
एक्सप्लोइटेशन किया है देखिए इनके पास
क्या है प्रोटेक्शन है इसके बाद आपने क्या
किया परसिस्टेंस जेनरेट किया ताकि सिस्टम
पर रुक तो आराम से फिर आपने क्या किया
यहां पर डिफरेंस
मतलब आपका क्या नाम है जो पूरा सर्वर
सिर्फ ये कमांड कंट्रोल
करके ठीक है और आपका मां कंट्रोल सेंटर से
सर्वर से आप अपने जो टारगेट सिस्टम है
उसको पुरी तरीके से बढ़िया से कंट्रोल कर
सकते हैं अब पूरा स्विच ऑफ है कंट्रोल में
ए चुका है इसके बाद आपने क्या किया इसके
लिए आपने किया डिस्कवरी मतलब ये का सकते
हैं आपकी एक नेटवर्क के अंदर अगर आपने एक
सिस्टम को मतलब एक सिस्टम पे एक्स जेन कर
लिया है तो उसके थ्रू और सिस्टम पे या उसे
नेटवर्क के अंदर और डिवाइस पे एक्सेस लेना
प्राइवेट के जा सकता है ठीक है इस तरीके
से इसका तू व्हीलर एक्सप्रेशन तो ते आपका
जो वो मिला हो मतलब आपको जो इनिशियल
अलेक्स मिला हो वो रूट यूजर का नाम मिला
हो या एडमिन यूजर का नाम मिलाओ तो आपको जो
मैक्सिमम प्रिविलेज जेन करना है
वो करना है इसके एग्जीबिशन करना है
इनिशियल क्या लिखा है ई
मूवमेंट मतलब ये इस तरह के अपने नेटवर्क
को इधर से जंप करना है हर तरफ से जो भी
कनेक्शन निकाल सकते हैं आपको उसे दम करना
है और ये सब कम हो गया आपके ठीक है फिर
आपका आउट आपको कलेक्शन करना है एक्स्ट्रा
फिल्ट्रेशन करना है ठीक है और आपका करना
है इंपैक्ट ऑब्जेक्टिव ठीक है ये लास्ट
स्टेप वगैरा उसे करना है करो ठीक है
बढ़िया जो कम करना है तो निकालना वाला
उसका इंपैक्ट क्या हो सकता है ऑब्जेक्टिव
ये चीज ए जाति है ठीक है तो ये तरीके से
एक पुरी चेन है कंप्लीट जैसे मैंने आपको
समझ सकते हैं
कम करते हो किस तरीके से एक जनरलाइज्ड वे
में होता है ठीक है ना बाकी चीज तो
रिपिटेटिव है होती रहती है
एक्टिवा में भी डिफरेंस क्या होता है अब
एक्टिवेट पैसे की कॉइन में डिफरेंस क्या
होता है की जो पैसिव रेकों होता है उसको
आप उसमें आप जो पब्लिक को इनफॉरमेशन
अवेलेबल है जो अवेलेबल है ठीक है मतलब आप
जो आपका टारगेट है ठीक है अगर साइट पर
रिकॉर्ड कर रहे हैं आप तो आपको वेबसाइट से
रिलेटेड जो भी जानकारी पहले से अवेलेबल है
ठीक है इंटरनेट पे अवेलेबल है कहानी भी
अवेलेबल है वहां से आप उन जानकारी को
एक्सट्रैक्ट कर रहे हैं ठीक है ये आपका हो
जाता है और आप जब किसी अपने टारगेट से
मतलब इंटरेक्ट कर रहे हैं टारगेट को पी कर
रहे हैं टारगेट से ही इंट्रोडक्शन कर रहे
हैं इंगेजमेंट कर रहे हैं उसके थ्रू आप भी
इनफॉरमेशन गदर कर रहे हैं वो आपकी
एक्टिविटी कॉन्सेप्ट में आई है जैसे की आप
जो वेबसाइट पर स्कैनिंग करते हैं ठीक है
तो पट करेंगे अपने क्या किया आपने पोर्ट
स्कैन जो किया उसने मतलब जो आपका टारगेट
है उसको रिक्वेस्ट भेजें किया ना तो वो
आपका एक्टिव कौन बनेगा ठीक है लेकिन वहीं
पे अपने कुछ इंजन का इस्तेमाल करके
तो वो आपके एक्टिव रिकॉर्ड में नहीं आएगा
वो आपके पैसे रेकों में ए जाएगा ठीक है तो
ये वही चीज अब इसके बड़े में हम आगे काफी
देखने वाले हैं पर एक जो बेसिक एजेंडा था
वो यही था की एक्टिव रेकों में पृथ्वी के
अंदर अंतर ही होता है की पैसे भी कौन आप
डायरेक्टली टारगेट से इंटरेक्ट नहीं कर
रहे हैं आपका जो कम है वो हो रहा है आपको
डायरेक्टली कम टारगेट से ही हो रहा है
आपका कम पब्लिकली अवेलेबल जैसे वो सीन कर
सकते हैं आता है एक तरीके से उसमें भी आप
पब्लिकली 11 इनफॉरमेशन का इस्तेमाल करते
हैं तो वो चीज भी इसमें आई है ठीक है ना
तो समझ गए होंगे पैसे भी नहीं डिफरेंस
क्या होता है
एग्जांपल दिया हुआ है इसमें थिंक ऑफ आईटी
लाइक उर लुकिंग आते टारगेट टेरिटरी फ्रॉम
एन फॉर विदाउट फ्रॉम एन फॉरेनर चीज विदाउट
स्टेपिंग फुट डी टेरिटरी ठीक है मतलब की
आपने दूर से दूरबीन लगा के देख रहे हैं
यहां बैठ के ठीक है उसके घर में जाकर देख
रहे हैं ये पेसूरी कौन कहे की एग्जांपल हो
सकता है अब यहां पर जैसे कुछ एक्टिविटीज
के बड़े में दिया हुआ है जैसे आप डीएनए से
रिकॉर्ड्स लिख सकते हैं मतलब पब्लिक डीएनए
सर जो साइट्स के नास रिकॉर्ड को हॉल करते
हैं ठीक है आप उनमें से उनके इनफॉरमेशन
देख सकते हैं अब जब रिलेटेड एड देख सकते
हैं जब एड्स रिलेटेड तू डी राइट ऑफ लाइट
जैसे की एग्जांपल ये एक बढ़िया चीज आप समझ
लीजिए
कोई कंपनी है ठीक है तो उसे कंपनी के बड़े
में जानना है ये naukari.com पे जाइए और
जाकर देखिए की उनसे मतलब वो क्या-क्या जब
पोस्टिंग जब ओपिनिंग्स रोल ओपन कर रहे हैं
वो ठीक है अब वो क्या एक्सपेक्ट कर रहे
हैं मतलब
कोई भी अगर उनकी रिटायरमेंट है मतलब साइबर
सिक्योरिटी एनालिस्ट की रिटायरमेंट है
एफरोन की रिटायरमेंट पर की है तो गड़बड़
की रिटायरमेंट में जो रूल लिखा होगा उसमें
लिखा होगा क्लियर डेवलपर को कम से कम यही
आना चाहिए ये लैंग्वेज चाहिए ये
टेक्नोलॉजी आनी चाहिए ये फ्रेमवर्क करना
चाहिए तो वो क्या क्या लिखा है उससे आपको
नजर ग जाएगी इसी कंपनी में ये जो
टेक्नोलॉजी है ये चीज उसे होती है ठीक है
इससे आपको तो नजर ग जाएगा की हां ठीक है
भाई जैसे कंपनी है वो ये ये टेक्नोलॉजी
इसका इस्तेमाल अपने यहां करती है यह
प्रोग्राम करती है और इसी टाइप के रफ के
लोगों को हीरे करती है ठीक है ना इससे
आपको नजर ग जाता है ये पब्लिक ही
इनफॉरमेशन है ये एक पैसे इनफॉरमेशन है ये
आपने कंपनी पूछा है लेकिन ये पब्लिक के
लिए अवेलेबल है ठीक है तो ये आपका ए जाएगा
इसमें रुको मैं
रीडिंग न्यूज़
कंपनी का तो कैसे हुआ था वह पार्टिकल कर
सकते हैं
वो कुछ नया अपडेट कर रहा है कुछ नया फीचर
ला रहे हैं तो कैसे ला रहे होंगे वो चीज
आप पढ़ सकते हैं इससे ठीक है ये सब पैसोड
नहीं ए जाएगा वही लिखा एक्टिविटी
कॉन्सेप्ट्स ऑन डी अदर हैंड कैन नोट बी
अचीव्स सो डिस्क्रिप्शन
करने की जो है जरूर होती है अपने टारगेट
से इस एग्जांपल है की जिनको फिट लाइक यू
चेक डी लॉक्स ऑन डी देवर और बिल अमन अगर
पोटेंशियल एंट्री प्वाइंट्स जैसे आप लोग
पूछ रहे हैं इस तरीके से आप ऐसा भी
एग्जांपल दिए हुए हैं कुछ टेक्निकल
टर्मिनल से कनेक्टिंग तू एन कंपनी सर्वर
जैसे एचटीटीपी और एमटीपी सर्वर है ठीक है
तो मैं इससे फायदा क्या है जैसे एग्जांपल
होता है वेदर के दिन के बड़े में आप जानते
होंगे क्या होता है की जैसे मां लीजिए कोई
एफटीपी सर्वर है ठीक है तो आपका करेंगे आप
सिंपल अपने विंडोज में एफटीपी कमांड दाल
के उसे एफटीवी सर्वर से कनेक्ट करने की
कोशिश करेंगे इससे क्या होगा पेपर उसका
वेदर आपको मिल जाता है इसमें आपको एक
एग्जांपल दिखता हूं एक अपना यहां पर
एमवेयर ओपन कर रहा हूं ठीक है और यहां पर
चालू कर देता हूं
इसको समझिए इस तरीके का ठीक है अब इसमें
क्या किया है पहले से अब इंस्टॉल कर सकते
हैं
मेरी कसम है चेक कर लेट हूं टैबलेट मैंने
इंस्टॉल किया था ठीक है 10 मिनट है चलिए
यहां पर यह चालू कर देते हैं
ओके
पोर्टेबल है ठीक है अब मैं यहां पर अब से
पोटेंशियल दाल रहा हूं
पासवर्ड दाल रहा हूं एम से फीडबैक
हो चुका है यहां पर ये पीडी डालता हूं तो
यहां पर साड़ी चीज ए रही है ठीक है अब मैं
इसका आई पी चेक करता हूं उसका आईपी एड्रेस
क्या है इसका आईपी एड्रेस 192.168 और 4738
ठीक है अब मैं क्या करूंगा मैं यहां पर
आता हूं मैं लिखना हूं 10 मिनट
192.168 डॉट 47 डॉट 138 ठीक है जैसे मैं
इंटर करूंगा तो ये देखिए क्या हुआ यहां पर
क्या हुआ ट्रिंग तू कनेक्ट कनेक्ट ठीक है
फिर यहां पर क्या आने लगा
तू ठीक और यहां पर चीज थोड़ी सी इनफॉरमेशन
टैग और लोग इंट्रोडक्शन तो ऐसे जनरल थोड़ी
लिखा होता है ये तो हमारे लिए लिखा हुआ है
वो तो ठीक है लेकिन आपको क्या मिला ये
मेटल तू
मतलब तू है ठीक है इस तरीके से इनका
इस्तेमाल
ठीक है लेकिन मां लीजिए की अगर मुझे लॉगिन
डिटेल नहीं पता है तो भी मुझे बस कनेक्ट
करने से ही इतना पोर्टेबल तू है ठीक है
इसको कहते हैं इस तरीके से एफटीपी के
अलग-अलग चीजों को कनेक्ट करते हैं तो आपको
ये मेटा है की एफटीपी का वर्जन कंसर्न हो
रहा है या हमेशा हर कैसे में नहीं होता है
पर ये सही से कॉन्फ़िगरेशन नहीं किया जाता
है इसको हायड नहीं किया जाता है तो ये शो
हो जाता है ठीक है इस तरीके से आप
एचटीटीपी को भी देख सकते हैं ठीक है तो ये
एक तरीके में आता है अब देखेंगे और में भी
ये कम करता है स्कैन करते हैं तो मतलब
स्कैन कर लेट है की हां भाई आपका एचडी भी
वर्जन ये है ओपन ये है तो वर्जन कहां से
लेकर आता है वर्जन इसी तरीके से लेक आता
है इन्हीं तीन कर तरीके से लेक आता है ठीक
है तो ये बैनर आता है इसमें कोई कर देता
हूं अभी लॉगिन तू लॉगिन भी हो जाएगा तो
आपको
लॉगिन हो चुका है ठीक है तो वही चीज है
लेकिन बैनर आपको बिना लॉगिन किया भी मिल
गया ठीक है
कंपनी ये देखिए ये सिर्फ टेक्निकल टर्म्स
में ही नहीं है त्रिकोण आपका टेक्निकल के
बाहर में भी आता है ठीक है जैसे की ये हुआ
कॉलिंग में कंपनी ने टाइम तू गेट
इनफॉरमेशन मतलब अपने कंपनी का कॉल किया और
किस तरीके से इंजीनियरिंग लगा के इंजन का
इस्तेमाल करके सोच लीजिए एक तरीका होता है
बेसिकली ताकि आप इनफॉरमेशन निकाल सके अपने
तरीके से ये मतलब किसी के मन को डाइवर्ट
करके ठीक है ना तो वो तरीका भी आता है
इसमें एंटरिंग का कंपनी
ये तो खैर लीगल चीज है या फिर ये आपको
कंपनी भी करवा शक्ति है मतलब अगर आपको
कंपनी के सिक्योरिटी टीम ने किसी ने हीरे
किया है मतलब इसलिए की आप कोई और
एंप्लॉयमेंट किया मतलब जैसे कंपनी ने क्या
किया की आपको
पॉइंट की आपने कंपनी की सिक्योरिटी चेक
करने के लिए ठीक है सिक्योरिटी चेक करने
के लिए तो उन्होंने कंपनी में आपको
इंट्रोड्यूस किया एंप्लाइज को ऐसा
इंजीनियरिंग मतलब उन्होंने कहा की ये
हमारे यहां नए इंजीनियर जॉइन किया है ठीक
है ये हमारे कोई भी बता दिया उन्होंने
सिस्टम या कुछ भी है ठीक है
और कंपनी
की और उन सब में जो वीक पॉइंट है उनको
फाइंड करने के लिए ठीक है ताकि फिर उसका
इस्तेमाल करके इन लोगों को सही तरीके से
ट्रेनिंग दिया जा सके और एम्पलाइज जो है
क्योंकि ह्यूमन एक मतलब गलती की भंडार
होते हैं और इस से में जो है वीक पॉइंट जो
है एंट्री पॉइंट होता है वो क्रिएट होता
है ठीक है एंपलॉयर्स की वजह से तो ये चीज
भी यहां पे आई हैं रिकॉर्ड में हर चीज आई
है यहां पर अब ओबवियसली आप ऑनलाइन बैठ के
कुछ कर रहे हैं तो इतना आप रिकॉर्ड नहीं
करेंगे मतलब जा के लेकिन ये सब चीज
रिकॉर्ड में ही आई है ठीक है ना
इसका मतलब बता देता हूं
आगे देख लेते हैं क्या यहां पर स्टार्ट
कंपनी का फेसबुक
जन के लिए ठीक है
आप किसी कंपनी की फेसबुक पर सजाते हैं ठीक
है ये उम्मीद रखते हुए की उनके कुछ
एम्पलाइज के हमें नाम मालूम चलेंगे ठीक है
अब यहां पर एक्टिव के लिए लिखना है पैसों
के लिए भी लिखना है इसका आंसर वीडियो पोज
कीजिए आराम से सोचिए और आपको टाइम ग रहा
है तो आराम से अलग होने वाला कुछ नहीं
बेबी अगर ग रहा है तो सोचिए आराम से कोई
दिक्कत नहीं है ठीक है ना ये बेसिकली मैं
आंसर देने जा रहा हूं ये होगा पैसे भी कौन
ठीक है यहां पर
ओके होगा आपने कंपनी के फेसबुक पे गया ठीक
है
अवेलेबल है उसमें अपने टारगेट से
डायरेक्टली इंटरेक्ट नहीं किया ठीक है ना
चला वो क्या हो गया
आपको पता है एमपी ट्रैफिक को भेजता है ठीक
है
अपने टारगेट को डायरेक्टली पिंग किया है
ठीक है
192.168
रिप्लाई कर रहा है मतलब ये एक्टिव हो गया
ना उसे इंटरेक्ट कर रहा हूं डायरेक्टली
उसको पता है की मेरा पी ए रहा है भाई अब
उसको लॉक्स कर रहा हूं लॉक बना रहा हूं वो
अलग बात है ठीक है लेकिन ये एक्टिव हो गया
ये एक्टिव होगा
नेक्स्ट है यू हैपन तू मीत डी आईटी
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर
मिलती है कंपनी के ठीक है यू ट्रेड तो उसे
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग तू गेट मोर इनफॉरमेशन
अबाउट डी सिस्टम और नेटवर्क इन फर्स्ट
लेक्चर तुम अपनी दिमाग लगा रहे हो कोशिश
कर रहे हैं आप उसे पर उसे आदमी से कंपनी
के बड़े में जानकारी निकालना का इसका
इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर नेट नेटवर्क का भी सब चीज
ये कैसा है अब ये एक अच्छा क्वेश्चन है
इसको आराम से दो मिनट सोचिए ठीक है तुरंत
आंसर दीजिए सोचिए और जस्टिफाई कीजिए अपने
आपको की आप वो आंसर दे रहे हैं तो मैं
इसका आंसर दे देता हूं इसका आंसर होगा
एक्टिव रिकॉर्ड क्योंकि मैंने पॉलीटिशियन
था की सिर्फ टेक्निकल टर्म से नहीं अब कम
कर रहे हैं वो भी उसमें आता है ठीक है ना
सोचेंगे जाके जो भी आप कम कर रहे हैं बस
अपनी डायरेक्टली इंटरेक्शन किया है वो
कंपनी का ये कंपनी का है तो वो डायरेक्ट
इंटरेक्शन ही है ठीक है ना तो वो एक्टिव
में ए जाएगा ये देखिए आंसर सही है ठीक है
ना
समझ में ए गया
डिफरेंस क्या होता है रेकों क्या होता है
बहुत सर मतलब तरीके से आप समझेंगे अभी कौन
तरीके होते हैं मतलब
सिक्योरिटी में त्रिकोण का मतलब क्या होता
है पहले क्योंकि हर चीज तरीके से नेटवर्क
नहीं कम कर रही है आपको बताइए वो चीज तो
आपके अंदर नेटवर्क के अंदर होगा कंपनी में
भी होगा ठीक है समझना जरूरी है आपके लिए
चलिए कुछ यूटिलिटी के बड़े में ठीक है ना
अब तक तो ये होगा की क्या होता है कैसे
होता है अब हम कुछ पैसे रिटायरमेंट
टेक्निक्स देखेंगे लेकिन एकदम बेसिक लेवल
पे दिखने वाले हैं पहले हम लोग बाद में हम
लोग एक्टिविटी देखेंगे और ये दोनों के बाद
जो मुझे लगेगा की अलग से भी कोई जरूर है
तो मैं वो अभी आपको एक्स्ट्रा बताऊंगा ठीक
है तो ये नहीं सोचना है की या ज्यादा नहीं
बताया जा रहा है तो वो टेंशन नहीं लेंगे
ठीक है ना चलिए तो बात कर लेते हैं पहले
हूं इस की बात कर लेते हैं तो ये हूं इसे
क्या होता है अब तक पेपर हुई डेट आप इसे
जो है डिटेल निकाल रहे हैं तो हूं इसे डी
रिक्वेस्ट और रिस्पांस प्रोटोकॉल डेट पर
आईएफसी 3912 स्पेसिफिकेशन ठीक है मतलब
क्या हुई तरीके की प्रोटोकॉल है हूं इस एक
डेटाबेस में ठीक है मतलब जो हूं इस सर्वर
होते हैं ठीक है वो किसी भी पॉइंट फोर
थ्री यहां पे दिया हुआ है स्टैंडर्ड 4 इस
पे इनकमिंग रिक्वेस्ट करते रहते हैं तो जब
भी आपको ही डोमेन खरीदने हैं ठीक है ठीक
है डोमेन रजिस्टर्ड पॉसिबल फॉर्मेटिंग तो
हूं इसे रिकॉर्ड करेंगे मतलब की जो एक
मतलब जैसे आपने सुना होगा दी है ठीक है
नाम चिप है इस तरीके से अलग-अलग वेबसाइट
है तो मुझे वेबसाइट होती है नाम ठीक है ये
जो वेबसाइट है ये वेबसाइट मेंटेन करती है
की संकेत जो जो भी डोमेन परचेज किया मतलब
रेंट पे ठीक है वो डोमेन जो लिए गए हैं
उनके बड़े में क्या-क्या इनफॉरमेशन है
किसने लिखवाया था कब तक है कब लिखवाया गया
था एडम कब तक रहेगा इन सब जितनी भी
इनफॉरमेशन है नाम सर्वर क्या होते हैं वो
सबके रिकॉर्ड को हॉल करेंगे अब वो सब कुछ
रिकॉर्ड को हॉल करते हैं तो उसको हुई
सर्वर का सकते हैं आप ठीक है तो उसे
डेटाबेस में से हम लोग जनरल यूजर कोई भी
रिक्वेस्ट करके जितनी डाटा अवेलेबल है
उसको निकाल सकता है ठीक है ये आपका हो गया
इसमें कुछ टर्म को देख लेते हैं रजिस्टर
मतलब की जिनकी खरीदा गया है बोर्ड रेडी है
ये स्टार कहलाने हैं देखिए की इनके थ्रू
वे विश्व रजिस्टर वास डोमेन नाम रजिस्टर्ड
ठीक है मतलब किस तरह डोमेन नाम को लिया
गया था रजिस्टर करवाया गया था ठीक है
किसने रजिस्टर कराया ऐसे कोर्ट की तरफ हो
सकते हैं की फाइल है ठीक है अगला कांटेक्ट
इन्फो और रेगिस्तान ठीक है रेजिस्टेंस
खरीदा है उससे कांटेक्ट
किया है ध्यान रखिएगा की यहां लिखा हुआ है
अनलेस की सर्विस ये वही बात है की आप मतलब
क्या जितने पसंद करते हैं उसके हिसाब से
आपकी जो काफी इनफॉरमेशन होती है वो नाम
डिटेल की सूची छुपा दिया है तो हूं इसे
अगर कोई हूं इसे वेरी करता भी है तो वो
जान नहीं पाएगा कैसे करते हैं वो देखेंगे
अभी हम लोग आगे पर अभी समय दीजिए इतना ठीक
है अगर क्रिएशन अपडेशन डेट है तो कमेंट
आता है कब खरीदा गया था कब एक्सपायर का ये
सब चीज हैं नाम सरवन वे सर्वर तू आस्क विद
आउट विद नाम ठीक है कहां से भी करना है
हमको
ठीक है चलिए तू गेट दिस इनफॉरमेशन
यहां पर
तीन साइड में ओपन कर लिए देख रहे हैं तो
पहले ही देख लेते हैं हम लोग
कॉपी कर लेट हूं चलिए गेट कर लेते हैं
यहां पर
ठीक है ये पब्लिक इनफॉरमेशन के बड़े में
बात करेंगे ये देखिए इनफॉरमेशन क्या है
आपका उत्तर
नाम चाहिए ठीक है इसका मतलब ये नाम चिप्स
कर दिया गया है
ठीक है
रजिस्ट्रेशन
कर रहा है ठीक है और भी चीज यहां पर हो
शक्ति है तो इस ट्रांसमिशन देखिए फिर यहां
पर एक फोन नंबर है और ये अभी मेरे ठीक है
मतलब गलतियां दिक्कतें ठीक है क्या कहना
मतलब ये है की और चीज यहां पे नहीं दी हुई
है इसको हायड कर दिया गया है ठीक है ना
क्योंकि यहां पर ये रेस्टोरेंट जो
इनफॉरमेशन है मेरे ख्याल से दूसरे वेबसाइट
में भी नहीं दिखाएगा देख लेते हैं
मैंने कहा था आपसे छुपा हुआ है ठीक है ये
चीज छुपा सकते हैं बहुत सारे इनफॉरमेशन
आपको मिल गई है टेक्निकल कांटेक्ट किसी ने
हायड नहीं किया होगा आपने देख सकते हैं
ठीक है उसके बड़े में पूरा देख सकते हैं
उसका इनफॉरमेशन ए गया है कैसे आप कर सकते
हैं
ठीक है जैसे
आपको जो भी रिकॉर्ड है वो मिल जाएगा इसमें
लिखना हूं
ट्राई हैक mi.com
|
[संगीत]
ठीक है|
यहां पर कुछ इनफॉरमेशन देनी है इनको
.कॉम रजिस्टर्ड कब रजिस्टर किया गया था तो
मैंने बताया आपको यहां पर रजिस्ट्रेशन
व्हाट इसे डी रजिस्टर
ऑनलाइन
ठीक है सेंट रिकॉर्ड जैसे हो गया आपका
टेस्ट रिकॉर्ड
है जस्ट कुछ एग्जांपल दिए हुए हैं यहां पर
ठीक है ना तो हम लोग देखने वाले हैं इसके
बड़े में तो स लुकअप यहां पर एक तू आता है
मेरे ख्याल से नहीं
आया यहां पर ठीक है
करते हैं
तो मां लीजिए ये मैं डालता हूं ट्राई 1
मिनट में दाल देते हैं कहता है इसमें ठीक
है देखिए किस तरीके से यहां पे कुछ बेसिक
इनफॉरमेशन ए गई है ठीक है ना ये क्या है
यहां पर कुछ आईपी एड्रेस भी आए हैं ट्रैक
में के ठीक है और आपका कुछ ये भी ए जाएगा
की ये सर्वर और रेंट है सभी सर्वर एड्रेस
क्या है ध्यान से देखिए इस चीज को पहचान
की कोशिश कीजिए
[संगीत]
क्वेरी है मेरी सॉल्व हो रही है अरे गेटवे
के थ्रू ठीक है अगर गेटवे में कंफीग्र्ड
है की कहां से ए गए पूछना है कहां से
डीएनए है लेकिन मुझे जो आंसर मिल रहा है
वो गेटवे से मिल रहा है ठीक है इसलिए यहां
पे दिया हुआ है की आपका जो गेट हुए
इस्तेमाल हो रहा है चलिए अब मैं आपको
दिखता हूं की इसमें आपको स्पेसिफिक वेरियस
कैसे करनी है स्पेसिफिक करियर करनी है
आपको मतलब की आपको सिर्फ ये रिकॉर्ड चाहिए
तो कैसे कर सकते हैं देखिए अब क्या करना
होगा आपको यहां पर आपको सिंपल लिखना है
[संगीत]
ये आपको कौन सा रिकॉर्ड चाहिए रिकॉर्ड
चाहिए ठीक है
ए रिकॉर्ड मुझे आंसर ये आपका एजुकेशन है
ठीक है इस तरीके से मैं नीचे आपको टी हा
टी रिकॉर्ड चाहिए तो यहां पे देख लेते हैं
टेस्ट लेते हैं
ठीक है इस तरीके से आप अलग-अलग वीडियो में
जो रिकॉर्ड्स हैं उनको आप जो है सर्च कर
सकते हैं अब बात है की इसकी जरूर क्या है
इसकी जरूर है आईपी निकालना के लिए सिर्फ
आपको टेस्ट रिकॉर्ड में कई सारे इनफॉरमेशन
मिल शक्ति है इंपॉर्टेंट ठीक है वहां पे
एफसी
आपको समझ ए जाएगा की इस तरीके से आप कस्टम
कर सकते हैं जैसे यहां पर अगर मैं यहां पर
लिख देता हूं
डॉट कॉम
करता है ये एड्रेस और ये एड्रेस पब्लिक
डीएस तो कोई भी रिक्वेस्ट कर सकता है ठीक
है गूगल के लिए आता है ठीक है और यह कोड 9
के लिए कई दो एड्रेस है तीसरी का स्वागत
है ये पब्लिक है बहुत सारे और होते हैं
यहां पर देख सकते हैं आप लोग अब सर लिस्ट
है ठीक है तो देख सकते हैं आप लोगों को
दिक्कत नहीं है इसमें फिलहाल मैं यहां पर
सवाल कर रहा हूं 1111 वाला अब मैं
इंस्टाग्राम चेंज होगा ये देखिए सर्वर में
क्या आया है इधर ये ए गया है अब का एड्रेस
ये ए गया है ठीक है और आपका जो भी रिकॉर्ड
था वो फेशियल के सामने ए गया है यही चीज
आप कस्टम सर्वर का इस्तेमाल कर सकते हैं
कस्टमर केयर
में सेटअप है वही उसे होने वाला है ठीक है
चलिए उसे करना है
इस तरीके से आप ऑनलाइन भी कर सकते हैं
इस तरीके से देख सकते हैं कोई वो नहीं है
की आपको नहीं करना है
क्या होता है ये आखिर कस्टमर रिक्वेस्ट हम
करते हैं क्यों करते हैं
आगे इसको आप अच्छे से कनेक्ट कर पाएंगे जब
हम लोग मूव करेंगे
उसके बड़े में वही चीज दी हुई है कुछ खास
नहीं है
यहां पर भी आप
कस्टम आते हैं वो लिख के यहां पर डोमेन
लिख के अपना रिकॉर्ड लिख सकते हैं की आपको
कौन सा रिकॉर्ड चाहिए
रिकॉर्ड चाहिए मुझे चाहिए आपका रिकॉर्ड
देखना है
की फ्लैग क्या है
हमारा इसको कॉपी कर लेते हैं हमें हमारा
फ्लैग मिल गया है
सब अपने लिए ठीक है ना
चलिए
पूरा हो गया हमारा
आगे देख लेते हैं यहां पर अब देखिए ये तो
हमारे सबसे पहले क्या किया हमने पहले कौन
समझा ठीक है टाइप समझो उसके यू समझा उसका
हमने दो यूटिलिटी देखिए जो थी अब हम दो
ऑनलाइन तो उसकी ही बात करने वाले हैं ठीक
है तो इन तरीके
से ओपन भी कर देता हूं
ठीक है
तो ये सब बेनिफिट होते हैं इनके जैसे यहां
पर मां लीजिए
डॉट कॉम
देखिए यहां पर आपको कब सर्विस के बड़े में
information.com के बड़े में जानकारी
मिलता है आपको ठीक है इसीलिए आपको
एक्स्ट्रा जो वेबसाइट होती है उसके बड़े
में आपको बताना चाहिए अगर आप इस्तेमाल
करते हैं तो कॉन्सेप्ट वही है कुछ नहीं है
कॉन्सेप्ट इसमें ठीक है लेकिन चीज आपको
एक्स्ट्रा मिल रही है कुछ चीजों के बड़े
में चल जाएगा ठीक है ना तो वही चीज आदि
हुई है
इसमें वो काफी फीचर मिलता है मतलब ग्राफ
वाला यहां पर एक्सल यानी प्रेजेंटेशन टाइप
कर सकते हैं रिपोर्ट डाउनलोड कर सकते हैं
अगर आप देख लेते हैं
अगर आपको
देखिए
इसको आप जूम जूम कर सकते हैं जो भी करना
चाहिए आप भी कट ले जाएंगे उसके हिसाब से
ठीक है तो यही चीज खास नहीं है तो ये बेटा
फीचर है इसको पीएनजी
इमेज
करता है
यहां पर तस्कर लुक आम डिनर विच वन विच इसे
वन इंटरेस्टिंग शब्दों में देखना है इसमें
डेट यू वुड डिस्कवर्ड इन एडिशन तू
www.block के अलावा कोई इंटरेस्टिंग
शब्दों में तो ब्लू ब्लू एक रिमोट है ठीक
है एडमिन टेस्टिंग ग रहा है और रिमोट
इंटरेस्टिंग ग रहा है हेल्प में क्या होगा
एडमिन ट्राई करते हैं
ये गलत आंसर है तो रिमोट आंसर होना चाहिए
ठीक है ना तो ऐसे जो मोस्ट वाइडऐली यूज्ड
है उसके बड़े में आपको जानकारी
सिक्योरिटी
कहा जाता है इसको ओपन कर देता हूं यहां पर
ऑनलाइन देखिए ये हर ऑनलाइन
से कर लेट है ताकि ताकि
उसकी पुरानी इनफॉरमेशन भी रहेगी ठीक है
यहां पर जो भी आईओटी कैमरा इनफॉरमेशन
करता है उनकी बैनर शो करता है देखिए यहां
पर इतना बाकी चीज जो भी है आपको दिया हुआ
है
यहां से यहां पर आपको मिल गया है इस टाइप
की जो आपको बैनर और इनफॉरमेशन आपको मिल
जाति है ठीक है फिलहाल उसका न्यूज़ नहीं
है
यहां पर 1 मिनट कम को सर्च करने को कहा है
और क्या नाम है
इनफॉरमेशन ए जाएगी यहां पर इसको ओपन कर
लेते हैं
इनफॉरमेशन है यहां पर मिलती है जो आपको
ऐसे डायरेक्टली नहीं मिलेगी हो सकता है
आपको डायरेक्टली एक्टिव रिकॉर्ड पे ना
मिले वो इनफॉरमेशन आपको यहां मिल शक्ति है
आईपीडी आपको मिल सकता है कितने आईपी
एड्रेस हो जाता है मतलब था लेकिन मतलब फिर
लगाया था प्राइस पे क्लिक हो गया तो ये सब
कम के लिए जो है स्टूडेंट कम आता है ठीक
है ना चाहे आप पीएफ सर्च करने के होस्टिंग
कंपनी कौन होस्ट कर रहा है ज्योग्राफी की
लोकेशन देख सकते हैं यहां से टाइप वर्जन
ये सब चीज आपको यहां से मिल जाति है ठीक
है
ना मिले ठीक है
अकॉर्डिंग तू व्हाट इसे डी सेकंड कंट्री
इन डी वर्ल्ड इन टर्म्स ऑफ डी नंबर ऑफ
पब्लिकली एक्सेसिबल ठीक है तो देखिए यहां
पर ये भी होता है
इसमें ठीक है
उसमें क्या कहा था सेकंड कंट्री सेकंड
कंट्री
कृपाचार्य
के पास था उसके सबसे
अगला क्वेश्चन क्या है व्हाट इसे डी थर्ड
मोस्ट आम पोर्ट ठीक है थर्ड मोस्ट आम
पोर्ट कौन सा है पर्ची के लिए 8080 ठीक है
तो 80 कर देते हैं यहां पर
सही आंसर है व्हाट इसे डी थर्ड मोस्ट आम
पार्ट यूज्ड के लिए थर्ड मोस्ट आम फूड कौन
सा है
थर्ड नंबर सबसे ज्यादा
ठीक है
मतलब आपका ये नंबर चिपक जाता है वन टाइम
का ठीक है
और एक्स्ट्रा बेनिफिट मिल जाते हैं ठीक है
तो अगर आपके पैसा ठीक है
परचेज कर लेना चाहिए ठीक है कम ही आएगा
आपका यहां पर हूं इसे रिकॉर्ड का यहां पर
दिया कमल
यूटिलिटी है अपने हूं इस डाटा की बेस्ट
समझा कस्टम डीएस कॉलेज के बड़े में समझाया
ठीक है कैसे कम आई है वो आपको समझा और
आपने कुछ एक्सटर्नल जो है यूटिलिटी जो
वेबसाइट है स्टूडेंट
के लिए
सभी कर देते हैं इसको
तो ये रूम जो है हमारा कंप्लीट हो चुका है
इसको आप शेर कर दीजिएगा यहां पे और अटैक
कर दीजिएगा अपने हिसाब से
चलिए
यहां पर मेंशन थे कुछ और भी टूल्स में जो
काफी फेमस है उसके बड़े में मैं आपको बता
देता हूं जैसे यहां पर एक टूल है वायरस
टोटल के बड़े में सब लोग जानते ही होंगे
ठीक है और यहां पर सर्च में आएंगे देखिए
अब देखिए मिलता है
वो मिल गए हैं ठीक है
ना इसके अलावा आपको और चीज मिलेगी कुछ
कुकर रिजल्ट इनफॉरमेशन कुछ और आपको दिखता
हूं यहां पर और भी चीज होगी एक्चुअली
देख लेते हैं कहां पे होगी
रिलेशंस में ठीक है तो देखिए यहां पर आपको
यहां पर शब्दों में मिल रहा है ठीक है
जितने शब्दों में जिसके पास है क्योंकि ये
शब्दों में सबको मिलन से रिकॉर्ड में नहीं
मिले थे ठीक है इस तरीके से पैसे भी
कॉन्शांइस की जो इनफॉरमेशन है कम आई है
उसके कॉरस्पॉडिंग की वाइफ की एड्रेस में
वो भी दिए हुए हैं आपको यहां से आपको काफी
ज्यादा अच्छा हो जाता है ये सब करते हैं
आपको वेबसाइट हैकिंग करते हैं ठीक है तो
आप आपको
पद्धति है क्योंकि आपको अलग-अलग शब्दों
में चाहिए स्कोप है
टेस्टिंग कर सकते हैं
ठीक है
ये समझेंगे
आपको यहां पर कई सारे जो है उसे मिल गया
ठीक है इस तरीके से शब्दों में जो चीज मिल
jaayengi.com ठीक है इस तरीके से आप काफी
ज्यादा रिटर्न मिल जाएगा आपको ये सब का
आपको ऐसे डायरेक्ट से मैं देखना है इसलिए
आप ऑटोमेटिक डिस्प्ले
चीजों को फ्रेश करके आपको देती है इसे ए
मास तू लोग यहां सब फाइंडर तू लोग यहां
इसके बड़े में आगे देखेंगे और भी ठीक है
तो इन सब कुछ का इस्तेमाल कर सकते हैं इन
चीजों को समझना के लिए तो आपके लिए तो एक
हिंदी काफी है लेकिन चलिए अब कोई समझ में
ए गया होगा ये सब चीज कर सकते हैं आपको
ऐसे एक ही फ्रेंड जाके देखना होगा ठीक है
फिर भी मैन्युअल इस बेस्ट तो एक बार मैं
आपको बताना चाहूंगा ये देख मशीन एक होती
है
ये इंटरनेट के पास रिकॉर्ड को मेंटेन करती
है मतलब आप किसी वेबसाइट को देख सकते हैं
की पहले कैसी थी लेकिन
खोल देता हूं सामने से
डैशबोर्ड ओपन कर लेट हूं यहां पर अपना
2018 में आई है उससे पहले का क्या दिखाएगा
2019|
18 फरवरी को 2019 में 18 फरवरी को ये
वेबसाइट कैसे दिखती है आपको दिखाएगा
इसको देख लेते हैं
4 अगस्त वेबसाइट
अभी भी ये काफी डिफरेंस है इसमें ठीक है
तो वही बताया नहीं मतलब अब ये जो पूरा
यूआई है फेसबुक काफी ज्यादा चेंज हो चुका
है तो अब कहेंगे आपके इसका फायदा क्या है
ये कोई पुरानी यादें ताज करने के लिए तो
बनी नहीं होगी वरना मैंने बताई होगी इसलिए
उसे हुआ है इसका ये है की बहुत बड़ा सा
होता है की वेबसाइट में पहले कुछ
इनफॉरमेशन थी इंपॉर्टेंट जैसे मैंने कोई
टेक्नोलॉजी जो पहले मेंशन की है हटा दी गई
वेबसाइट से तो आप डायरेक्ट मशीन से जाके
पहले के समय लिया गया हो तो मैं आप देख
सकते हैं की छोटी के भाई तुम ये उसे करते
हो मतलब आज भी करते हो ठीक है इनफॉरमेशन
है वो आपके कम की है इसीलिए आपको वेबसाइट
के जो पास सीट स्टेटस है वो देखने के लिए
बेनिफिट मिल जाता है ठीक है ना इसलिए
मैंने आपसे कहा था की ये वेबसाइट कम की है
जो करना कम आई है तो इस टाइप के कुछ टूल्स
हैं और भी टूल्स हैं मतलब है क्योंकि
इसमें कोई अंडे नहीं है मुझे कॉन्सेप्ट है
ठीक है वो करते क्या है वो भी कम करते हैं
अलग-अलग साइज को गूगल ड्रॉप्स तरीका होता
है ये आपको पता ही है तरीका होता है तो
ठीक है तो वो सब तो वही तरीके हैं पर जो
एक चीज है वही है ठीक है बाकी दुकान
पढ़ेंगे तो उसमें हम लोग जरा देखेंगे अपने
सभी चीजों को देखेंगे लेफ्ट तो करेंगे
अपने तरफ से जो जरूर होगी एक्स्ट्रा उसने
एड करेंगे ठीक है ना एक्टिव रिकॉर्ड में
तो आज के लिए इतना ही पेंट करते हैं हम
लोग उम्मीद करता हूं की आप लोग को ये पसंद
आया होगा सेशन इंटरेस्टिंग लगा होगा और
प्लीज आपसे रिक्वेस्ट है की जो भी फीडबैक
का अच्छा लगा तो वो भी बता दे यार
टेलीग्राम तो बताओ कमेंट बताओ ठीक है
अच्छा ग रहा है तो हम लोगों को भी समझ
आएगा की कौन सी सीरीज कंटिन्यू करनी है
कौन सी रानी है अगर दूसरे में इंटरेस्ट है
तो इस चीज आप बताएंगे रिस्पांस नहीं ए रहा
है व्यू भी अच्छा रहा है कम से कम लेकिन
रिस्पांस नहीं आएगा कम से रिस्पांस कीजिए
टाइप करके रिस्पांस कीजिए कोई आपको
कार्टून दे रहा है आपके पास में जो है ठीक
है सर्च कर रहे थे अच्छा है बड़ा है
क्योंकि ये बोलिए उसे चीज में ठीक है ना
तो आज के लिए सेशन को यही पे और करते हैं
फिर जल्दी आएगा और मैं उम्मीद करता हूं की
रिस्पांस मिलेगा अच्छा है तो अच्छा लिख
दीजिए बड़ा है जो भी फीडबैक है ठीक है
लेकिन देखिए इस को चैनल पे लिखिए ठीक है
तो थैंक्स पर वाचिंग नेक्स्ट क्वेश्चन
कंटिन्यू करते हैं हम लोग बाय बाय